have you noticed that whenever the
medical experts say the science says it
ends up justifying the left's most
insane demands now I can remember when
the science told us that Trump was
overreacting by blocking travel from
China and I can remember when the
science told us not to wear masks I can
also remember when the science said that
reopening states early would mean
skyrocketing deaths the hospitals will
be overloaded well of course the science
and VOC by the so-called experts was
wrong every step of the way but that
hasn't stopped the media from blaring
alarmist warnings
well now the science has deemed it ok
essentially actually two pack together
outdoors and large crowds to protest in
the name of liberal political causes in
fact it may be the most effective Cova
treatment ever it was outdoors where the
virus is much more likely to be
dissipated into the air on the other
hand we had people who were exposed to
tear gas and smoke where coughing was
more prevalent which is something it
does aerosol eyes the virus we also had
people who were arrested held in
vehicles such as buses for hours before
they were processed and then put in
jails overnight all which would increase
transmission but as of this morning we
don't yet have any convincing evidence
this has been a big problem ok that's
what we meant by herd immunity mr.
osterholm well meanwhile of that same
science considers it unacceptably
dangerous to attend large indoor
gatherings I'm sure it's just a
coincidence that these super spreader
events happen to exactly match the
campaign rally that Trump had planned
over the weekend if I was giving advice
the administration on this I would say
that they should withhold large
political rallies right now it's a bad
idea for states that are already seeing
increasing increases in cases to then
have these large this perfect storm
setup you get a stadium with potentially
1 million people as the campaign is
saying has bought tickets is not as a
setup for
better event and I'm sure it's just a
sheer luck that the hyperventilation
over a second wave of Kovac cases
conveniently tracks precisely or Trampas
set to travel thousands will gather
Saturday night and Tulsa to listen to
the most famous non mask wearer in the
country President Donald Trump but Co
vid is here in Tulsa it is transmitting
very efficiently confirmed cases in the
county just climbed 30 percent in a week
blamed by the Health Department on large
indoor gatherings remember its
hospitalizations and ICU beds that
really count but that's alright just
move the goalposts
well Democrats wish that the president
would just put off campaigning
indefinitely obviously or ideally until
after the election of Joe Biden who all
things considered they just prefer to
stay in his basement until the
inauguration day meanwhile Anthony Fauci
a man obviously suffering from media
withdrawals he resurfaced over the
weekend and what can only be described
as a one-man effort to depress us all
now that we're slowly starting to get
our lives back ever so slowly he told a
British newspaper I would hope that we
could get back to some degree of
normality within a year or so but I
don't think it's this winter or fall the
medical deep state strikes again well
the bottom line for all of us is that
the president in his campaign should
simply not react to any of this alarmist
Cova drivel from here on out none of
these people sadly including dr. foutch
II can be really taking all that
seriously anymore given what we've seen
because science just like journalism and
entertainment has become obscenely
politicized now why did none of these
people wailing about the health hazards
of trumps future Ally's voice any real
sustained concern about the shoulder to
shoulder protesters screaming at the top
of their lungs some not wearing masks
I'm taking them on and off the carry
BLM and t4 nasty anti-trump sides no
worries
why aren't they decrying the risk a
picnic that took place in Central Park
over the weekend
now my friend's son couldn't get married
in New Orleans my high school buddy
couldn't visit her dying brother but
angry agitators felt free to conduct a
rave outside DC Mayor Bowser's home
yesterday at least there was some social
distancing going on there well
considering how much ma'am Mayor Bowser
has fomented in DC it's poetic justice
I'll support the protesters in that one
now in New York Governor Cuomo reported
just yesterday forty Cova deaths that's
a 96 percent decrease from the peak
that's good news but despite all that
amazing progress Governor Cuomo is still
threatening businesses and localities
because they're all having too much fun
and making a little money watch I am
warning today in a nice way consequences
of your actions
we have 25,000 complaints statewide I'm
not going to turn a blind eye to them
not long after you issued that threat
hundreds of thousands of protesters
filled the streets of Brooklyn for a
black trans lives matter rally now are
they going to face consequences for not
social distancing or not wearing masks
or not wearing them properly or not
wearing them long enough or you get the
point well not from Mayor Bill de Blasio
they won't he's ordered the city's vast
army of kovat contact tracers not to ask
people if they've been protesting well
that's not totally true de Blasio did
punish Brooklyn's Orthodox Jewish
community for the heinous crime of going
to the park for their sins de Blasio
sent city workers to weld shut a park
gate in the Jewish community of Borough
Park in Brooklyn today now the only
thing that should be
shut down at this point are the
Democrats political fundraising
operations given what's going on here
they need to be punished at the ballot
box for how badly they botched this from
day one and at the same time President
Trump must convey a calm and confident
message I don't know if something akin
to keep calm and wash our hands don't
sneeze on people now it's back to the
work for the rest of us got to get our
country back he must also not allow
states to unfairly punished their own
residents with these prolonged freeze
outs in education and business I mean at
some point these shutdowns are
tantamount to a state taking of property
without due compensation you see the
constitutional argument I'm making and
that's a virus our American system will
tolerate no longer and that's the angle